สวัสดีค่ะครูนี้สวัสดีครับครูหญิงสวัสดี
นักเรียนทุกคนด้วยนะครับสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนเดี๋ยวเราเขียนวันที่ก่อนนะคะ
วันนี้ครับวันนี้วันพุธครับ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 10 ครับเดือนอะไร
คะเดือนสิงหาคมครับ
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
[เพลง]
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
อะไรคะปีค.ศ 200
ค่ะ 8 โมง 57 นาที
แล้วเมืองที่ครูหญิงอยู่ตอนนี้กี่โมงครับ
ครูหญิงอยู่ตอนนี้ 9 โมง 57 นาทีค่ะก็ตอน
เช้าเหมือนกันน้องอีกไม่กี่นาทีเนี่ยนะคะ
ของผู้หญิงก็จะ 10 โมงแล้ว
ตอนเช้า
วันนี้วันนี้กินข้าวแล้วเพราะว่าคนนี้
กลัวว่าอัดวีดีโอไปแล้วก็จะหิวใช่ไหมคะ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
[เพลง]
แล้วแต่อารมณ์ด้วยว่าเออรู้สึกว่าช่วงนี้
อยากทำบุญก็คืออยากเอาเงินที่เรามีหรือ
ของที่เรามีไปให้คนอื่นได้ใช้หรือไปเอา
เงินไปให้วัดครับใช่
ถ้าแบบทำบุญเนี่ยไม่ได้หมายถึงเงินอย่าง
เดียวหรือเปล่าคะจริงๆคือจริงๆแล้วมันก็
จะเกี่ยวกับเงินทั้งหมดนั่นแหละครับเพราะ
ว่าถึงเราเอาของไปให้วัดหรือว่าเอาของไป
ที่เราจะเรียกกันว่าไปบริจาคใช่ไหมของพวก
นั้นเนี่ยเราก็ต้องใช้เงินซื้อแล้วเอาไป
ให้เขาอยู่ดีหรือเป็นของเราใช้แล้วมันก็
เป็นของที่เราเคยเอาเงินไปจ่ายมันก็จะ
เกี่ยวกับเงินนั่นแหละครับแต่ว่าเงิน
เปลี่ยนเป็นของหรือเป็นเงินให้เขาไปเลย
เพราะว่าอย่างถ้าเอาเงินแล้วก็ไปทำบุญผู้
หญิงก็อาจจะน้อยนะคะแต่บริจาคของเนี่ย
บ่อยเพราะว่าเมื่อก่อนเป็นคนชอบซื้อของ
ผู้หญิงเนาะชอบซื้อซื้อแบบแล้วมันเยอะอ่ะ
ค่ะครูนิคแล้วทีนี้ปีที่แล้วอ่ะเราจะย้าย
บ้านไงมันก็ต้องเก็บของที่เรามีทั้งหมดก็
เลยจะมีพวกเสื้อผ้ารองเท้ากระเป๋าหรือว่า
โต๊ะอะไรอย่างนี้ค่ะก็จะเอาไปบริจาคเนี่ย
ค่อนข้างบ่อยแต่จริงๆมันก็เป็นการบริจาค
ที่เราเสียเงินไปเยอะเหมือนกันนะ
ใช่ก็เสียเงินเยอะเหมือนกัน
ถ้าคือจริงๆทำบุญเราจะทำบุญด้วยเงินหรือ
ด้วยของที่เราเคยมีเคยใช้แล้วไม่อยากใช้
แล้วก็ได้
เนี่ยจะบริจาคของหรือทำบุญด้วยของเนี่ย
บ่อยเหมือนกันยกตัวอย่างเสื้อผ้าคุณนิก
อาจจะอาจจะเป็นความคิดแปลกๆแต่ว่าคุณนิค
จะเปลี่ยนเสื้อผ้า
ทุกๆ 2 ปี
ทำไมอ่ะคะคือคุณนิดจะไม่ชอบเก็บเสื้อผ้า
ไว้นานๆแล้วคือคุณนี้คิดว่าถ้าคุณนิสัย
มากที่สุด 2 ปีเสื้อผ้ามันยังดีอยู่มัน
ยังไม่ได้เก่ามากแล้วเราอ่ะจะเอาไปบริจาค
เอาไปให้คนอื่นใช้เขาก็จะใช้ได้นาน
หน่อยนึงใช่เราไม่ต้องรอให้เสื้อผ้าเรา
ขาดเราค่อยไปบริจาคสำหรับตัวนี้คือคนนี้
ก็คิดว่าเออ 2 ปีก็ดีเหมือนกันคนนี้ก็จะ
ได้มีเสื้อผ้าใหม่ๆที่มันมาให้มันตาม
แฟชั่นเขา
ใช่แล้วก็มันก็ดีกว่าการที่เราทิ้งหรือ
เอาไปทำผ้าเช็ดพื้นใช่ไหมคะเพราะว่าบาง
เสื้อผ้าหลายๆตัวมันยังดีอยู่เลยอ่ะ
เราก็คิดว่าเออจริงๆก็ยังไม่ได้เบื่อแต่
ก็ให้คนอื่นที่เขาอยากใส่อยากใช้ดีกว่า
แล้วเราก็ซื้อใหม่มาได้ของที่มันใหม่กว่า
แล้วก็แบบจะมีชุดนอนที่คุณจะเก็บไว้นาน
หน่อยแค่ชุดนอนมันต้องแบบเก่าๆนานๆแล้ว
มันนิ่งๆใช่
ค่ะแต่ว่าแบบบางคนใช่ไหมอย่างผู้หญิงก็จะ
เห็นแบบบางคนเนี่ยเขาก็จะเหมือนสอนลูกอ่ะ
ให้รู้จักการทำบุญ
จะเป็นการทำบุญแบบการบริจาคอ่ะค่ะก็คือ
การที่เอาของที่เรามีแล้วก็แบ่งให้คนอื่น
บางที่ของเล่นใช่ไหมของเล่นบางทีเด็กๆบาง
คนน่ะมีของเล่นเยอะเพราะว่าอาจจะมีลุงป้า
น้าอาปู่ย่าตายายทุกคนเนี่ยซื้อตุ๊กตา
ตุ๊กตาหมีตุ๊กตาบาร์บี้เหมือนซื้อมาให้
เยอะๆแต่พอเราเริ่มโตไม่ได้เล่นแล้วอ่ะ
พ่อแม่เขาจะไม่ได้แบบให้เก็บเอาไว้อ่ะเขา
ก็จะเหมือนสอนว่าโอเคเราไม่ได้ใช้แล้วเรา
เอาไปบริจาคให้น้องๆคนอื่นใช่เพราะว่าที่
ไทยหรือหลายๆที่มันก็จะมีบ้านเด็กเค้า
เรียกว่าบ้านเด็กกำพร้าใช่ไหมคะ
ไม่มีพ่อแม่อ่ะค่ะเด็กๆที่ไม่มีพ่อแม่ก็
จะมีบ้านแล้วก็จะมีคนเนี่ยดูแล
ใช่ก็จริงๆแล้วเนี่ยการทำบุญนะครับไม่
จำเป็นต้องไปที่วัดอย่างเดียวมันก็มีหลัง
ที่ที่เราไปได้ก็คือทำบุญคือเราเราเอาของ
เอาเงินที่เรามีเนี่ยไปให้คนอื่นก็คือ
เหมือนกับทำความดีนะไม่จำเป็นต้องไปที่
วัดอย่างเดียวอาจจะไปที่บ้านเด็กกำพร้า
ที่ครูหญิงบอกหรือไปไปที่ไหนล่ะพยาบาลไหม
ใช่พยาบาลก็ได้โรงพยาบาลหรือกำลังคิดว่า
โรงเรียน
โรงเรียนที่ต่างจังหวัดก็ได้ใช่ผู้หญิง
กับคุณนี้ก็อาจจะรวมเงินกันแล้วก็ซื้อพวก
ลูกฟุตบอลลูกวอลเลย์บอลอย่างนี้ค่ะหรือมี
อาหารมีขนมทำแล้วก็เอาไปให้เด็กๆในก็เป็น
การทำบุญนะใช่ก็มันก็เป็นการทำบุญให้กับ
คนที่เขาเหมือนไม่มีโอกาสมากเหมือนเรายก
ตัวอย่างนะครับแล้วก็คิดว่าปัจจุบันนี้
เนี่ยมันก็มีการทำบุญอีกแบบนึงที่
ยกตัวอย่างเหมือน unisav หรือ Green
Peace พวกนี้ที่เราทำบุญกับบัตรเครดิต
ก็คือเหมือนกับว่าแต่อันนี้จริงๆอันนี้
ความคิดของคุณนิดยังไม่เคยทำคุณไม่เคยได้
ยินเราก็ตอนนี้ในกรุงเทพฯก็มีบ้างที่เรา
จะเห็นตามรถไฟฟ้าที่มีคนมายืนแล้วก็บอก
เกี่ยวกับการทำบุญก็คือเขาจะหักเงินจาก
บัตรเครดิตของเราเป็นรายเดือนนะ
ก็คือถ้าสมมุติว่าเราเราบอกกับเขาว่าโอเค
เราจะทำบุญกับเขาด้วยบัตรเครดิตแล้วเราก็
บอกจำนวนเงินเหรอคะว่าเท่าไหร่เขาจะกำหนด
ไว้อยู่แล้วครับว่าโอเคไม่เป็นรายเดือนนะ
เราก็มีให้เลือกว่า 500 บาท 1,000 บาท
1,500 บาทก็ให้เราเลือกว่าอันไหนแล้วเขา
ก็จะบอกโอเคก็จะมีเงินจำนวนนี้ที่จะหัก
ออกจากบัตรเครดิตทุกๆเดือน
เราทำบุญด้วยกันบริจาคเงินช่วยเหลือพวก
unisave  peta อะไรอย่างนี้พวกหน่วยงาน
ที่หน่วยงานต่างๆครับ
[เพลง]
ผู้หญิงเคยเห็นไหมหรือเคยทำไหม
เคยทำค่ะแต่เคยเห็นเคยเห็นแถวๆ BTS เมื่อ
ก่อนที่ทำงาน BTS เจอบ่อยมาก
คือเราก็ไม่รู้ว่าณตอนนั้นนะคะเราก็คิด
ว่าจริงหรือเปล่า
คือเรารู้สึกว่าแบบเหมือนเราด้วยความเป็น
คนไทยเรารู้สึกสบายใจมากกว่าที่เราจะแบบ
ทำบุญโดยที่เราเอาไปให้กับคนนี้เลยที่เรา
รู้ว่าว่าเขาเนี่ยเดือดร้อนจริงๆเขาอาจจะ
ไม่มีเงิน
ไม่มีบ้านอยู่แล้วเราได้เหมือนไปช่วยแล้ว
เราเห็นนะคะอ่าว่าเขาได้รับสิ่งที่เรา
ช่วยจริงๆก็เลยรู้สึกแบบจริงหรือเปล่า
อะไรอย่างนี้ตอนนั้นนะ
คะเคยทำไหมไม่เคยใช่ไหมเพราะว่าคุณนิดยัง
มีความคิดว่าการทำบุญเนี่ยถ้าไม่ใช่ของก็
เป็นเงินสดดีกว่าแล้ว
ถ้าพูดคือทุกวันนี้เนี่ยมันมีเกี่ยวกับ
โจรหรือพวกสแกนที่มันใช้บัตรเครดิตคุณนิด
ก็เลยกลัวในการที่จะต้องเอาบัตรเครดิตให้
ใคร
ที่เขาที่เห็นในทุกวันนี้นะครับมันก็เลย
เวลาทำบุญด้วยบัตรเครดิตเนี่ยคนนี้จึงไม่
ค่อยกล้ายังไม่อยากยังรู้สึกว่ามันมีอะไร
แปลกทำไมทำบุญจะต้องใช้บัตรเครดิตแล้วคุณ
นี้ก็ยังคิดว่าบัตรเครดิตมันเหมือนมัน
เป็นเงินในอนาคตอ่ะมันไม่ใช่เงินเราเอง
ทำไมเราต้องไปยืมเงินในอนาคตมาทำบุญ
แบบมันเหมือนกับว่าอีกอย่างนึงก็คือการทำ
บุญมันต้องอยู่ที่เราสบายใจด้วยไหมคะว่า
แบบเฮ้ยทำไมต้องมาบังคับเราให้ทำบุญทุก
เดือนเดือนละ 500 บาททั้งๆที่แบบเดือนนี้
เราอาจจะรู้สึกว่าฉันเงินเยอะจังเลยฉัน
อยากทำบุญแต่พอเดือนหน้า
ไหนจะวันคริสต์มาสวันแม่วันพ่อวันเกิดใคร
ต้องใช้เงินเราอาจจะไม่มีเงินไงคือการทำ
บุญมันต้องสบายใจอ่ะคุณหญิงก็รู้สึกว่า
เอออยากทำเป็นแบบนี้ฉันอยากทำโอเคฉันเอา
เงินสดแล้วก็ไปช่วยอาจจะให้กรีน Please
unisave แต่เราอยากทำไงเราไม่เดือดร้อน
ใช่ไหมคะใช่ๆถ้าแบบนั้นอ่ะคุณนิกะโอเค
กว่า
แล้วก็อะไรนะเกี่ยวกับทำบุญเมื่อกี้เมื่อ
กี้นึกขึ้นได้
อ๋อที่ตอนที่คุณนิคทำงานอยู่สายการบินเขา
ก็มีเหมือนกันขนาดของก็เป็นเกี่ยวกับ
เหมือนคล้ายๆองค์กรของกรีนพีชยูนิเซฟนั่น
แหละแต่
ของคุณของสายการบินที่คุณนิดทำงานด้วย
เนี่ยเขาจะเป็นเหมือนกับบริจาคเงินคือ
ต้องทำประกาศนะบนเครื่องบินทุกทุกครั้ง
ที่ทำงานว่าโอเคเดี๋ยวจะมีเดี๋ยวจะมี
แอร์โฮสเตสหรือสจ๊วตเนี่ยออกไปในเขตออกไป
ในออกไปใน
ห้องผู้โดยสารเหรอคะใช่
ใน Cabin แล้วภาษาไทยเรียกว่าห้องผู้โดย
สารโอเคก็คือจะมีคนเดินในเครื่องบินนี่
แหละแล้วก็บอกว่าเนี่ยจะเป็นบริจาคถ้าใคร
จะมีใครมีเงินหรือไม่ได้อยากจะเอาเงินที่
คือเหมือนกับว่าถ้าเขากลับมาจากกับที่
ประเทศออสเตรเลียแล้วเขามีเงินของ
currency อื่นๆแล้วไม่ได้อยากจะแลกกับ
เป็นเงินของบ้านเขาก็เอาเป็นบริจาคได้
เพราะว่าเรารับเงินทุก currency
อันนี้เข้าใจนะเพราะว่าอย่างครูหญิงมา
อเมริกาอย่างนี้ค่ะเงินที่เป็นเหรียญน่ะ
ครูนิกเข้าใจเลยใช่คือแบบได้มาในกระเป๋า
อ่ะเป็นกรรมเลยค่ะแล้วแบบอันนี้คืออะไร
อ่ะแล้วเราเป็นนักท่องเที่ยวเราไม่จำเป็น
ที่จะต้องแบบใช้ไงแล้วเราก็คิดผู้หญิง
เนี่ยก็จะเอาเงินตรงนี้ค่ะคืออันนี้ก็ไม่
รู้ว่าทำบุญไว้คนไทยเรียกทำบุญหรือเปล่า
คือบางครั้งก็จะมีคนที่เขาแบบไม่มีบ้าน
น่ะเขาจะอยู่ที่ตามถนนหรือว่าเขาอาจจะขอ
คือที่นี่เขาจะมีคนเหมือนเปิดประตูให้เรา
ครับตามแบบพวกฟาสต์ฟู้ดหรือว่า Starbucks
อย่างนี้ค่ะแบบเขาก็จะเปิดประตูให้เรา
แล้วพอเราเข้าไปปุ๊บเราเดินออกมาเขาก็จะ
เปิดประตูให้เรา
ผู้หญิงก็จะแบบบางทีก็จะเอาเงินที่เป็น
เหรียญอย่างนี้ค่ะซึ่งเราไม่เข้าใจอ่ะใช้
ไม่เป็นเราไม่คิดจะใช้อยู่แล้วอ่ะเพราะ
ส่วนใหญ่มันก็ใช้บัตรเครดิตได้ใช่ไหมคะก็
ให้เขาเหมือนกันมันก็เป็นความคิดที่ดีของ
สายการบินนะเพราะว่าเงินเหรียญส่วนใหญ่
เราไม่ได้แลกคืนเป็นเงินของเป็นเงินบาท
อยู่แล้วใช่เพราะจริงๆเงินเหรียญเนี่ยใน
ประเทศไทยเขาก็ไม่รับและเขาก็ไม่รับแลกนะ
เขาจะรับแค่เงินเป็นแบงค์แล้วก็นั่นแหละ
ครับเขาก็เหมือนไอเดียเป็นความความคิดของ
สายการบินที่เขาทำกับหน่วยงานเพื่อว่าเอา
เงินตรงนี้เนี่ยไปให้กับเด็กหรือไปให้กับ
Project ที่เขาคิดเอาไว้ในแต่ละเดือน
เขาก็จะเนี่ยแหละมันก็จะได้เงินจากผู้โดย
สารนะให้เยอะมากทั้งเหรียญทั้งเป็นแบงค์
เพราะว่าบางทีเขาเหมือนกับมีเงินใน
กระเป๋าหนึ่งเหรียญสหรัฐแล้วจะเอาไปแลก
เวลาเขาไปถึงบ้านมันก็ได้ไม่เยอะเขาก็เลย
ไม่เอาเสียเวลาค่ารถเอาบริจาคดีกว่า
มันก็จะเป็นว่าผู้โดยสารบริจาคเยอะไหม
เยอะคือจะเยอะเวลาเขากลับที่ออสเตรเลียนะ
ถ้าเขาไปเที่ยวเนี่ยไม่ค่อยมี
ใช่เหมือนแบบเครื่องบินจากไทยแล้วก็จะบิน
ไปออสเตรเลียหรือใครก็ได้นะเป็นคนไทยคน
ที่ไหนก็ได้จะไปเที่ยวออสเตรเลียอันนี้
ไม่ค่อยมีใช่ไหมคะ
ไม่ค่อยมีคือแต่ถ้าเที่ยวบินจาก
ออสเตรเลียกลับไทยอันนี้อาจจะเยอะหน่อย
เพราะว่าเออก็ไม่มีเงินอยู่แค่เนี้ยแล้ว
ก็จะเก็บไว้ทำไมเอาไปแลกกลับเป็นเงินไทย
ก็เสียค่ารถเสียค่าน้ำมันไม่คุ้ม
ไม่รู้จะเอาไปทำอะไรด้วยอ่ะแค่เงินเหรียญ
บาทบ้านเราเองก็เยอะมากแล้วอ่ะ
อันนั้นก็เป็นการทำบุญอีกอย่างหนึ่งที่
สำหรับคนนี้ก็แต่ก็เห็นว่าสายการบินหลาย
สายการบินเขาทำแบบนี้เหมือนกันนะ
เหมือนผู้หญิงเคยเห็น 1 ครั้งไหมอันนี้
ไม่แน่ใจนะคะ
แต่ว่ามันจะมีอีกอย่างนึงที่อันนี้ก็เป็น
การทำคือเห็นมีมันมีข่าวเหมือนผู้หญิง 1
คนเนี่ยเขาทำก็เลยคิดได้ว่าเอออันนี้เรา
ก็เคยทำเหมือนกันนะก็คือ
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงเนี่ยจะผมยาวใช่ไหมคะผู้
หญิงบางคนน่ะค่ะเขาก็จะไว้ผมยาวอ่ะให้ยาว
มากๆ
แล้วก็ตัดแล้วก็เอาผมที่เราตัดอย่างนี้
สมมติตัดตรงนี้เนาะผมตรงนี้ของเราอ่ะค่ะ
แต่เขาจะกำหนดนะคะคุณหญิงจำไม่ได้ว่าผม
ที่เราตัดออกแล้วเราจะเอาไปบริจาคทำบุญ
สำหรับทำวิกผม
ให้กับผู้หญิงที่แบบอาจจะให้คีโมใช่ไหมคะ
คีโมแล้วผมมันร่วงผมมันร่วงใช่ไหมแล้วก็
ต้องใส่วิกอย่างนี้ค่ะผู้หญิงหลายๆคนน่ะ
จะทำแบบผู้หญิงที่ผู้หญิงเคยรู้จักหลายๆ
คนก็ทำแต่จำไม่ได้ว่าผมที่เราตัดออกมา
เนี่ยแล้วเอาไปบริจาคอ่ะค่ะมันยาวกี่
เซนติเมตรเนี่ยอันนี้จำไม่ได้แต่ก็คิดว่า
15 เซนติเมตรไหม
12-10 เท่าไหร่หรือเปล่าไม่แน่ใจแต่
อย่างครูหญิงอย่างนี้ไม่ได้นะคะมัดได้แค่
นี้ไม่ได้อย่างน้อยผู้หญิงต้องไว้ผม
ประมาณเกือบๆกลางหลังอ่ะ
จริงๆอันนั้นก็เป็นการทำบุญเหมือนกันก็
คือทำบุญมันก็เหมือนกับเหมือนกับเอา
เหมือนกับทำความดีไม่จำเป็นอะไรก็ได้ที่
คนอื่นเอาไปใช้ประโยชน์ได้
เพราะว่าส่วนใหญ่ถ้าเราไม่ได้แบบว่าทำ
อาหารแล้วก็ไปวัดใช่ไหมคะไปวัดอ่ะที่เป็น
ทำบุญแบบนั้นทำบุญที่เหลืออย่างอื่นที่
เราทำไม่ว่าจะคุณนิดบอกว่าสายการบินหรือ
เรามีเสื้อผ้าเอาไปให้คนอื่นนะคะหรือว่า
พวกองค์กร Green  Please  unise  save
ใช่ไหมคะตัดผมไปช่วยคนอื่นมันก็คือการทำ
บุญด้วยกันบริจาค
ซึ่งเหมือนไม่รู้เห็นข่าวหรือเปล่าอ่ะค่ะ
ที่ประเทศไทยอ่ะบริษัท
ฮาตาริอ๋อได้ยินเหมือนได้เห็นข่าวแบบผ่าน
ๆนะที่เขาบริจาคเงินกูมากๆใช่ไหมครับใช่
นักเรียนนะคะ
900 ล้านบาทนะเลขนี้นะนั่นแหละที่เป็น
ข่าวที่เห็นอยู่เหมือนกันแต่เขาบริจาคให้
กับโรงพยาบาล
รามาธิบดีนะคะน่าจะเป็น
ให้เพราะโรงพยาบาลนี้ก็เหมือนอาจจะช่วยคน
ดีก็เป็นโรงพยาบาลใหญ่นะเหมือนน่าจะ
เหมือนกันกับศิริราชเพราะว่าคือเพื่อนคุณ
นิคเนี่ยเขาเป็นหมอแล้วเหมือนกับเขาให้
เลือกเขาให้เลือกระหว่างศิริราชกับ
รามาธิบดีคิดว่าน่าจะอยู่ในกลุ่ม
แต่ก็ดีครับดีเหมือนกันอันนั้นเมื่อกี้
นิดนึงพูดถึง
วัดก็บางครั้งนี้ก็พรุ่งนี้ก็ไปทำบุญก็
คือเหมือนกับไปให้อาหารเขาเรียกว่าอะไรทำ
บุญอาหารเพลใช่ไหมถ้าเป็นพระเลี้ยงพระ
เลี้ยงพระใช่
ครับ
คือเราทำอาหารไม่ใช่วันพระคือคนไทยจะทำ
อาหารไปวัดส่วนใหญ่จะเป็นวันพระหรือวัน
เกิดวันเกิดเราอย่างนี้ไงวันเกิดเราเรา
อยากทำบุญใช่ไหมคะเราก็อาจจะทำอาหารแล้ว
ก็ไปเลี้ยงพระหรือไปเลี้ยงเด็กสมัยเด็ก
ที่เด็กบ้านเด็กกำพร้าเด็กไม่มีพ่อไม่มี
แม่
[เพลง]
เขาแล้วเขาสามารถเอาไปใช้ประโยชน์ต่อได้
หรือว่าคือการช่วยคนอื่นเนาะโดยการช่วย
เหลือคนอื่น
เอามาคุยให้นักเรียนฟังนะคะแต่ว่าวีดีโอ
นี้เนี่ยคิดว่าหมดเวลาแล้วเดี๋ยวผู้หญิง
กับคุณนิคก็ไปก่อนนะคะแล้วเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอ
กันใหม่ในวีดีโอหน้าโอเคครับไว้เจอกัน
ใหม่สวัสดีครับ